Everyone today we are talking about the
types of biodiversity, so the
first type of biodiversity is genetic
diversity, it means diversity at the
level of genes, in this we talk about
different varieties of mango like
Alfazon Dhari or if we talk about rice.
Talking about different varieties, some have
small green size, some have big, second type
of diversity is species diversity,
this diversity comes in the level of species,
as it is seen that
many species of MCBNS are present in some places,
OK.  D third and D last
one is ecological diversity within this
diversity D is ecosystem level
standing and weather in countries is very
constant and different ecosystems cannot exist there compare it
with India so this date is which everyone thanks you